so let's have a go find the area of the
region bounded by this curve here and
the x-axis okay so in the previous
question I just kind of let you have a
go yourself at the sketch and then we
are picked up at the identify integral
step this time I'm going to do switch it
around so I'm going to sketch this with
you once we identify the integrals then
I'm going to let you have it go and see
if you can finish out this whole answer
so to have a go at this guy here you'll
notice it's a cubic like in our previous
example but it's a much more complicated
one so in order to work with this we're
going to use a trick from the first
question which is some factorization
okay so have a look at this all three
terms x cubed 5 x squared 6x there's a
common factor you can take out can you
type it quick and tell me what it is
what can I factorize out nicely done
Sasha gets in for first that everyone
else is very very close behind fantastic
so let's factor out that X and what does
that leave us in the brackets well take
a home the x out x squared X cubed
rather you get an x squared take an X
out of 5 x squared you just get a 5x and
then take the x out of the 6x and you
just a 6 now I can factorize further
than that we shouldn't be surprised that
there's more factorization to do because
it is a cubic after all x squared plus
5x plus 6 I reckon you can write for me
the factorization the whole thing in the
brackets it's not a um it's not a
complicated bunch of symbols can you
guys type it for me what am I going to
get as the two things in the brackets
remember it's a quadratic searching for
that pair of numbers that multipliers to
6 and add to 5 yeah very close Mary and
that's a it's a common area to make
you've got to check closely for what
you're doing well done yet we've got the
the right values there so the two values
are 2 & 3 so I get X plus 2 X plus 3 and
at this point
well done Alexis I've factorized
completely now I've done this so that I
can sketch okay now remember just like
before each one of these factors tells
me and intercept right the first one
tells me intercept of x equals 0 the
second one x equals negative 2
and in this last one x equals the
negative three okay so let's go ahead
and let's do our quick and dirty sketch
here remember it's quick and dirty
because we only need to see enough of
this thing to know what it's going to
look like so that we can identify the
appropriate integrals so I I'm gonna go
a little bit over this way all right so
when I put in my three X intercepts that
we've identified thank you homes are
well done here's my zero intercept if I
go roughly to scale on to three so
there's my negative two intercept and
then there's my negative three intercept
okay now I need to thread the needle
that goes through all of these and just
gets a general cubic shape okay so what
I'm gonna get is a shape rather like
let's choose a different color here
rather like this wow that's really messy
but you know what it'll do me okay
because what I really need to see here
is where is this region or in this case
as you can see regions plural right so
if you've drawn a sketch roughly looking
like this and again if it's messy no big
deal it just needs to look close enough
to this to identify the integrals you
can see that I've got this area came
back to the violence question before
this is an area under the curve and then
the next one here is an area above the
curve but in both cases it's an area
that's bounded by the x-axis okay so
this is the area that I'm after these
two green ones together I've sketched
but to identify the integral that
matches with this right you have to be
very cautious you've got one here I'm
going to call this a one for area one
and then you've got this guy here a two
right well to work out each of them
you've got two different integrals so a1
is equal to alright let's see I'm gonna
go from negative 3 to negative 2 that's
my lower bound to my upper bound of the
function here X cubed plus 5x squared +
6 X with respect to X there's a 1 but
when I want to go ahead and do a
- right this is where I have to use my
sketch to say hole but it's beneath the
axis so this is going to be a negative
area I'm gonna put that minus sign at
the front and then I put in the
boundaries that are relevant so it goes
from negative 2 all the way to 0 and
then I have so I'm just going to be a
bit cheap here I've got exactly the same
thing that's being integrated ok no this
is the point R I'm going to pause I held
your hand through that last bit I reckon
you guys can work out these integrals
and then get some solutions for me how'd
you do that Rahul this is an example of
what I was trying to talk about before
some students will look at this and
they'll say oh ok I've worked out I've
got to go from negative 3 to negative 2
to 0 and they sort of say well I can
combine all those together don't write
this I can combine all this together to
get my area from negative 3 to 0 and
because I know that oh I want to make
sure that some parts are negative and
turn positive I'm just going to put
absolute value signs around the whole
thing
now I'll go ahead and let you proof for
yourself that that will not give you the
answer in fact you'll get a completely
different thing this is one of those
places where you have to be very
cautious absolute value signs don't just
fix things if you know where to put the
absolute value signs which is to say
you're supposed to put them here then I
would say well you might as well just
put a minus sign because if you could
recognize that that was the part beneath
the axis you could recognize that a
negative is going to get you the right
solutions so I'm just going to say of
the tens of thousands I've times have
marked questions like this when I see
students throw around absolute value
signs kind of indiscriminately that's
more of an indicator that they're not
sure what to do where is the best
answers people say oh I know exactly
when it's positive so I'll just take the
integral as it is and I know when it's
negative so I know when to put a minus
sign out the front
thanks for whole hope that's clear so
let me get rid of this since it's not
the answer we want I'll give you um ya a
minute or so to go ahead and play a
catch-up work out those integrals and
once you've got a number go ahead
post it in the chat and then I'll know
when you're good to go
you
so for starters let's have a go over
here I'm just going to be working on
this one integral I've got the minus
sign at the front and then I go from my
primitive function so here I've got X to
the 4 on 4 plus 5 X to the 3 on 3 plus
we saw this as a 6 X to the 2 on 2 also
known as 3x squared and then I'm going
from negative 2 to 0 okay how are we
going so far if you're watching along
can you give me a thumbs-up if that
makes this do well give me a thumbs down
or a confused face if you're if you're
not following along ok Miriam you're
happy Lawrence how about you mate you
said you need to help with this area as
well thanks Alana ok nicely so if I
asked for a confused face I don't know
if that qualifies this is that just
you're not happy with this or whatever
okay
I'm gonna I'm gonna plow ahead okay
hopefully it will make you yeah thanks
though I find I asked for that okay I'm
gonna evaluate this now so I've got my
negative side still at the front what am
I gonna get in here well I go top
boundary takeaway bottom boundary now in
this case my top boundary is 0 and I've
got look at them carefully I've got a 0
to the 4 here which is going to become 0
I've got 0 cubed 1 X 0 squared all
becoming 0 so I get a 0 here
there's my upper boundary and then I
subtract my lower boundary ok let's have
a go here so I've got negative 2 to the
power 4 on 4 I've got 5 lots of negative
2 cubed or 1/3 and then I've got 3 lots
of negative 2 squared close bracket okay
so Jason if negative 2 was the top
boundary there would be no negative out
the front yes that's right I would be
switching them around if I made negative
2 this the top boundary what I'm doing
is I'm reversing the boundaries which is
the same as taking out a factor of -1
which is in fact exact
what I'm about to do right now I'm just
going to do it at a later step so have a
look at what I've got here right
this is I should say there's actually a
big set of brackets around there that no
one caught or maybe you decad but you
were too polite to say anything about it
what have I got here this is a - outside
of F of B takeaway F of a that's what
I've got there
okay so calling your mind back to the
fundamental theorem of calculus okay now
you can see that minus sign I can
substitute in there I can factor it out
or factor it in rather and I get capital
F of a take away F of B so this is
instead of upper bound take away a lower
bound it's lower bound take away upper
bound which is the same as turning me
integral upside down okay so what I've
got here is a whole bunch of negatives
cancelling basically importantly it's
let me highlight it for you it's going
to be this negative cancelling with this
negative so that leaves me with
everything that you saw up in here all
of this so let's drag this over yeah
okay
so now I'm ready to go ahead and
simplify that so the negatives here I've
got four of them so they're all gonna
cancel out and the twos I get 2 to the
power 4 which is 16 over 4 16 over 4
which I think we all know is 4 we have I
got here 5 times negative 2 cubed so
that's going to be 5 times negative 8
all divided by 3 plus 3 lots of negative
2 squared so that's 3 lots of 4 okay so
I've got what we say 4 at the front here
minus 40 on 3 plus 12 this is 16
takeaway 40 on 3 what's 16 that's um
that's 48 on 3 take away 40 on 3 so this
gives us the 8 on 3 that people worked
out early yeah okay so that took a bit
longer because we were working out by
hand but let me zoom out so you can see
the whole thing is that okay and you
Miriam does that satisfy you to see how
I got that
yes Lawrence so when I went through this
in class I did want to show you how like
the important thing for me was not the
number crunching and then I'm a country
obviously matters because you can't get
the answer without the number crunching
but I wanted to show you how to combine
those so now you can see the actual
working you can see I probably just
didn't want everyone because I think
most people had already gotten to the
answer at that point but hopefully for
you guys this shows what my actual
working will look like unfortunately
it's a little bit long and messy and
that's because I picked a slightly long
and messy function to choose to
integrate but nonetheless that is the
solution okay so it was the very last
step just the thirty-two over twelve so
all I wanted was I knew that these two
where the a1 and the a2 that I wanted to
combine so even though eight over three
is the simplest way to write that
fraction I need to combine it with a
five over twelve so I need common
denominators right so that's why I chose
to multiply by 4 over 4 that doesn't
change the fraction it just writes it
with different denominators so that
gives me 32 over 12